держава гнійна яку перетворилася
Російська Федерація заявляє що вибори
пройдуть на територіях які зафіксовані в
російській Конституції але мабуть це
єдина в світі держава гній яка в своїй
Конституції має регіони до яких вона не
має жодного відношення і збройні сили
України найкраще щодня Кремлю доводять
що немає сьогодні запорізької
Херсонської Донецької областей в складі
Росії а по Луганській області в нас теж
ідуть важкі бої і Ми дякуємо збройним
силам України які доводять що і Крим і
Донецьк і Луганськ і звичайно Запорізька
й Херсонська область - це є Україна І
дуже важливо щоб ми з вами разом на
парламентському вимірі попрацювали з
нашими партнерами що не визнання цих
виборів має призвести до посилення
санкцій проти режиму Путіна ми всі
уважно слідкували за зустріччю яка
відбувалася зараз в Саудівській у справі
Ми вітаємо розширення країн які
долучилися до цього діалогу і дуже
важливо щоб на цих зустрічах в першу
чергу мова йшла про посилення санкцій
проти Росії в тому числі щоби до цього
долучились країни які сьогодні
допомагають Росії обходити санкції
отримуючи товари подвійного призначення
ви знаєте але важливо що вони тільки
російські злодій і вбивці понесли
покарання а й колаборанти з Марії оновою
ми тільки повернулися з Харківщини і
Донеччини і там нас просять жителі які
пережили окупацію щоби дбр не кошмарили
сьогодні
опозицію а зайнялося нарешті разом з СБУ
колаборантами які насправді допомагали
ворогу складаючи списки учасників АТО їх
родин про українських родин щоби всі ці
люди які причетні до депортації
українських дітей до незаконної
паспортизації українців а це є злочинами
геноциду були покарані і ми як Верховна
Рада які прийняли закон по колаборації
маємо цього